Special Afferents
of the Head and
Neck Video 1 Olfaction
and Gustation
Or Smell and Taste
The following three
videos provide
a summary of the
special senses for
the head and neck.
Much of this information
is distilled from
chapters 8 and 10 of
Moore's Clinically
Oriented Anatomy. As
with previous lecture
videos, I recommend
focusing on the blue
pages slash blue boxes
in these chapters as
they will contain
the most clinically
relevant information
about these structures.
This lecture video
series completes our
trek through the 12
cranial nerves. We will
cover cranial nerves
1, 2, and 8, with brief
cameos from cranial
nerves 7, 9, and 10.
Today's video
covers the two most
underrepresented
senses in our body,
starting with cranial
nerve 1, olfactory.
This is the least
researched cranial
nerve, and the one
that is the least
valued in everyday
life. Humans just
don't emphasize
our sense of smell.
The structure
typically referred
to as the
olfactory nerve is
in fact the
olfactory stalk.
This structure is
comprised of the
olfactory tract
and olfactory bulb.
The olfactory nerve
is not a true nerve.
These structures
are anterior
extensions of the
forebrain that end in
multiple little
terminal nerves.
This is the human
olfactory bulb. Compared
to other animals
such as rats, dogs,
alligators, or even
dinosaurs such as
Tyrannosaurus rex,
it's pretty clear just
how much humans have
reduced our sense
of smell. The olfactory
bulbs rest above
the cribriform plate
of endocranium.
From the olfactory
bulbs, 10 or so nerves
descend down through
the cribriform plate of
the ethmoid bone. The
nerves traverse the
cheese-grater-like
cribriform plate until they
reach their destination
in the mucosa of the
superior-most portion
of the nasal passage.
Although we often
associate the nasal
passage with the
sense of smell,
only the superior
-most portion of the
nasal passage—a
relatively small part of
the entire nasal
passage—is capable of
olfaction. The remainder
of the nasal passage
is used to filter,
warm, and humidify
air before it enters
the lungs, and then
to reclaim that
water on the way out.
The three internal
swellings we see in
the nasal passage
are called conchi.
They are named
for their shape,
which resembles
a conch or conch.
Think of a conch
shell on the beach.
Only the superior
concha houses
olfactory epithelium.
This epithelium
extends over the
superior concha
and the adjoining
medial nasal wall.
This is where the
olfactory nerves end.
Formation of the
superior concha is
variable, with some
people not having
a superior concha
at all. Instead,
the olfactory nerves
are distributed
over the roof of
the nasal passage.
Air entering the
superior concal
portion of the
airway, referred
to as the
superior meatus,
slowly traverses the
olfactory epithelium.
Odorant molecules
get captured by the
olfactory mucosa,
transporting the
molecules to olfactory
receptor cells.
This triggers the
cells, depolarizing them
and sending the signal
back through the
cribriform plate and
into the olfactory
bulb where they synapse
with another specialized
group of cells,
called mitral cells.
These cells send
the olfactory signal
back to the rest of
the brain along two
different olfactory
striae, a lateral
and a medial stria.
The olfactory nerve
is the only cranial
nerve that directly
connects to the
cerebrum. All other
cranial nerves connect
from the brainstem.
Clinical correlate.
The most common
clinical case related
to the olfactory system
is anosmia, or the
inability to smell.
Anosmia can be
acquired from multiple
sources, including
damage to the
olfactory epithelium
itself or the
cribriform plate. In
many instances, there
is a congenital
component involved.
This pathology has
received more attention
recently, as anosmia
used to be a hallmark
of early variants of
the COVID-19 infection.
Anosmia largely affects
a person's quality
of life. People with
anosmia will comment on
food being less
appetizing. This is due to
the intimate connection
between smell and
taste, which we will
cover later in the video.
People suffering
from anosmia may find
themselves in urgent
care more often
due to accidental
food poisoning as the
lack of smell
receptors prevents them
from recognizing when
food has spoiled.
The second special
afferent in
this video is
taste, or gustation.
Taste is unique as it
is the only special
afferent to span
multiple cranial
nerves. The sense of
taste is conveyed to
the brain on cranial
nerves 7, 9, and 10.
Taste is the ability
to recognize chemical
signatures on items
that touch the tongue,
which is the main organ
for taste sensation.
The capacity to
taste also exists
on part of the oral
soft palate and
pharynx, but
these all pale in
comparison to what
we see on the tongue.
Gustation on the
tongue is made possible
due to numerous ridges
on the surface and
sides of the tongue
mucosa. These ridges
are called lingual
papillae. There are
four types of lingual
papillae, filiform,
foliate, fungiform,
and circumvalate.
Circumvalate papillae
are the least numerous,
with the typical
person having between
8 and 12 papillae.
In contrast,
filiform papillae
are extremely
numerous and cover
most of the tongue.
However, filiform
papillae are
also the only
lingual papillae
that lack taste
receptor cells.
Instead, these
papillae function in
gripping food items
with the tongue. The
taste-sensing
structures on the other
three papillae are
called taste buds.
Taste buds are a
collection of afferent
neurons that come
together to form a single
taste-sensing structure.
Each taste bud
has between 50 to
150 taste receptor
cells bundled together
to form a structure
that looks a bit like
a hand of bananas.
A single lingual papilla
may have hundreds
of taste buds across
its surface. There
are five recognized
taste categories.
Sweet, salty,
sour, bitter,
and umami, or savory.
Hold up a minute.
What about spicy food?
That's a taste, isn't it?
Though we often
associate spiciness with
food flavors, spice
is not a true taste.
There are no spice
receptors on the tongue.
Instead, spice
is conveyed back
to the brain
via these guys,
our nosoceptors.
Nosoceptors are our
pain receptor cells.
Spices, typically
from capsaicin,
irritate our mucosal
lining, and that pain
is relayed back to
the brain via our
nosoceptors. In
particular, our thermal
nosoceptors, hence why
spicy food feels hot.
The unique way
that individuals
interpret this pain
is what determines
a person's
spice tolerance.
This is also why you
can taste with your
eyes, nose, genitalia,
and **** region.
Theoretically, any
part of our body
that has nosocceptors
can taste spicy
food, though this
is often limited
to just parts that
contain mucosa.
So, not a true
taste category, but
still a fascinating
phenomenon. Alright,
back to taste buds.
Taste receptor cells
are sensitive to only
one of the five taste
types mentioned here.
However, the
distribution of taste
receptors within even a
single taste bud is such
that every part of
the tongue mucosa can
taste any of these
five taste categories.
Different nerves
convey taste to the
brain from different
parts of the tongue.
The posterior one
-third of the tongue
uses the glossopharyngeal
nerve, cranial
nerve 9, to convey
taste information.
A small portion of
the posterior part
of the tongue, as
well as bits of the
oral soft palate and
pharynx, have their
taste information
conveyed to the brain
via the vagus nerve,
cranial nerve 10.
By far the largest
contributor to gustation
is the facial nerve.
This nerve conveys
taste information to
the brain from the
anterior two-thirds of
the tongue via a special
branch of facial
called corda tympani.
We briefly covered
the course of
corda tympani in my
previous lecture.
The nerve travels
through the middle
ear cavity and
exits the skull
through the petro
-tympanic fissure.
From here, corda
tympani hitches a
ride with the lingual
nerve, cranial
nerve 5-3, to
reach the tongue.
As with the hypoglossal
nerve and the
cervical plexus,
even though both
lingual and
chordotimpany appear like
a single nerve at
this point, their
two epineural sheaths
remain separate.
So why is the
tongue this rich
tapestry of nerve
associations?
The answer has
everything to do with
how our tongue forms
embryologically.
The tongue starts
in the fourth
week as a series
of swellings from
the first four
pharyngeal arches.
Each pharyngeal arch
has a specific nerve
associated with it. As
the tongue develops,
it drags in contributions
from these four
different cranial
nerves. In the case
of chordotimpani, we can
see that the anterior
two-thirds of the
fully developed tongue
are covered by
trigeminal, not facial.
However, earlier
in development, the
facial nerve's
distribution was more
present thanks to
contributions of pharyngeal
arch 2 to the
developing tongue.
During this time, our
protochordotimpani
nerve splits off from
the protofacial nerve as
the pharyngeal arch
swellings are dragged,
the first pharyngeal
arch as the tongue forms.
Clinical correlate.
Taste is second only
to olfaction when
it comes to under
-representation in
medicine and research. The
biggest clinical
correlate associated with
gustation is agusia.
This is a loss of the
sense of taste, and
it often goes hand in
hand with anosmia.
Agusia has also seen a
relatively recent surge
in interest, as loss
of taste was another
factor commonly
associated with early
strains of a COVID-19
infection. Other ways
of acquiring agusia
include exposure to
toxic chemicals, illicit
drug use, or head
trauma, which can cause
a temporary or
permanent loss of taste.
The loss of a sense
of taste, as with the
loss of sense of smell,
can place a person
at risk for inadvertent
food poisoning as
they cannot taste food
that has gone bad.
Largely, agusia affects
the quality of life
for the patient as
the inability to taste
lowers hunger levels
and often leads to poor
nutrition as the
affected person may try
to compensate for a
weakened gustation by
substituting more salt
or sugar into their
food. Much like anosmia,
there are currently
few treatment options
available for agusia.
Smell and taste are
deeply intertwined
with one another. They
offer two different
means of analyzing
chemicals from
the environment, or
chemosensation. They
are also an example
of a coupled sense.
Coupled senses are
two or more senses
that work together
to perform a third
function. For olfaction
and gustation,
that third function is
the concept of flavor.
Although we typically
associate flavor with
just taste, true flavor
requires both the
sense of smell and the
sense of taste. It has
often been stated that
80% of flavor comes
from just the smell of
food alone, though as
far as I know there are
no real quantitative
measures behind that
statement. The importance
of smell in the
flavor of food can be
made obvious when a
person suffers from a
stuffy nose. Food eaten
during this time is often
considered bland and
pretty flavorless.
If you have used air
travel recently, then you
may have also noticed
that airplane food
is remarkably bland
despite its high salt and
sugar content. The
high altitude and heavy
air recirculation in
airplanes lowers the
ability to detect airborne
odorants, producing
a weakened sense of
flavor. You can test this
the next time you take
a trip on a flight
by holding on to some of
the snack food offered
to you on the plane
and tasting it some
10 to 20 minutes after
you have landed and
resettled your body.
The now grounded snack
items should taste
noticeably sweeter or saltier
compared to their
taste on the plane. The
coupling of smell and
taste occurs at multiple
sites of integration
in the brain,
including the thalamus
and orbitofrontal cortex.
You will learn more
about these structures
in neuroanatomy
next semester.
This brings us to
the end of video one.
Special Afferents of the
Head and Neck, Video 2,
Cranial Nerve 2, Vision
This is, by far,
the most important
special afferent
that we have.
Around 30-60% of
our brain is devoted
to processing
visual information.
The optic nerve
is similar to
the olfactory
nerve in that
it is also not
really a nerve.
As with our
olfactory stalks,
the optic nerve
is actually an
anterior extension
of the brain.
The optic nerve travels
rostrally in the
anterior cranial fossa
before exiting the
endocranium through
the optic canal. The
nerve ends in a large
evagination more
affectionately known
as the eyeball. That's
right, our eyes are
both special afferent
organs and the terminal
nerves of the optic
nerve. The eyeball can
be divided into three
layers, a fibrous
layer, a vascular layer,
and a neural layer.
The fibrous layer
of the eye consists
of the outside of the
eyeball itself. This
is called the sclera.
Anterior to the eyeball
is a specialized
part of the sclera
called the cornea.
The anterior portion
of the eye is housed
within an extraocular
compartment known
as the conjunctival
layer. This compartment
serves to hold and
moisten the eye.
Both the sclera and the
cornea are comprised
of the same collagen
fibers. The only
difference is that in
the sclera, all the
collagen fibers are
arranged in this helter
-skelter pattern,
resulting in the fibers
blocking all incoming
lights. In the cornea,
these same fibers
are all arranged
parallel to each other,
allowing light to
pass through the
translucent fibers and
into the eye. The
sclera is tough,
protecting structures
inside the eye and
blocking out light
from other directions.
It also serves as
the distal attachment
for all six of the
extraocular muscles.
The cornea is the window
for light to enter
in the eye. The fibers
of the cornea are
misaligned just enough
to block out the high
energy photons such
as those from most
ultraviolet rays. It
also acts as the main
refractor of light for
the eye. More on that in
a minute. Blood flow to
the sclera is sparse,
and the cornea
itself is completely
avascular, relying on
capillary beds, lacrimal
fluids, and aqueous
humor to bring nutrients
to the cells of the
cornea. Lastly, the
cornea is highly sensitive
to touch. The second
layer of the eye is
the vascular layer.
This consists of
the iris, ciliary
body, and the
choroid. The iris is
the most noticeable
part of the eye.
It lies just
anterior to the lens.
It makes the
color of the eyes,
and it is responsible for
changing the size
of the pupil.
The iris is comprised
of two different
muscles that form
a ring around the
pupil. The innermost
portion of the iris
houses the
constrictor muscle for
the pupil, known as
sphincter pupillae.
This is a ring of
smooth muscle that
is circularly arranged
around the pupil
and when contracted,
will shrink the
size of the pupil. It
is parasympathetically
innervated.
In this image,
sphincter pupillae is
partially covered by
another muscle, the
dilator pupillae.
This is a ring of
radially arranged smooth
muscle fibers that,
when contracted,
pull open the eye
equally from all
directions, resulting
in dilation.
the dilator pupillae is
sympathetically driven.
Now, due to the
radial orientation of
the muscle fibers,
the dilator pupillae
takes longer to contract
than its counterpart,
sphincter pupillae.
Or to put it
another way, you can
constrict your eyes
a lot faster than
you can dilate them.
Posterior to these
muscles is a very thin
layer of pigmented
epithelium. Iris
color is determined by
the amount of melanin
granules produced
by melanocytes in
this pigmented
epithelium. These cells
produce melanin, which
gets trapped between
the fibers of the
two iris muscles.
The more melanin
produced, the darker the
eyes are. Brown eyes
carry the most melanin
in their pigmented
epithelium, whereas green,
hazel, and blue represent
decreasing amounts
of melanin in that
pigmented epithelial
layer. The iris also
serves as a landmark,
demarcating the
end of the anterior
compartment of the eye.
The anterior compartment
of the eye contains
aqueous humor, which
maintains pressure
inside the eye and
helps distribute
nutrients to the cornea.
The ciliary body lies
posterior to the iris.
It is a muscular
ring located at the
corneoscleral junction.
The ciliary body is the
attachment site for
the lens, and it is
responsible for the
production of aqueous
humor in the anterior
compartment of the eye.
The lens is attached
to the ciliary body via
a collection of fibers
known as zonular
fibers, or the zonule
of Zinn, which sounds
like a Lord of the
Rings or Game of Thrones
character. When the
ciliary body is at rest,
the zonular fibers are
taut and pull on the
lens, changing its
shape by making it
thinner and straighter.
When the ciliary body
contracts, the zonular
fibers loosen and the
lens bounces back to
its natural biconvex
shape. This changing of
lens shape is important
for accommodation,
which will be covered
a little later in this
video. The ciliary
body receives
parasympathetic innervation.
The final layer of
the vascular layer is
the choroid. It
comprises the majority of
the posterior compartment
of the eye and is
the main source of
sustenance for structures
inside the eyeball.
It is a dark,
reddish-brown layer. The
red in red-eye pictures
from cameras is the
choroid reflecting
back through the lens.
The choroid consists
of an extremely dense
mesh of capillaries
that deliver nutrient
-rich blood to the
retina. The choroid
is tightly attached
to the posterior part
of the retina, but
only loosely attached
to the anterior part.
Attachment is
maintained by pressure
produced by the
vitreous humor, which is
a gelatinous mass
that fills up most of
the posterior
compartment of the eye.
The innermost layer of
the eye is the neural
layer, and it consists
of the retina. The
retina houses around
150 million different
neurons, and it can be
divided into a neural
layer, again, where the
light-sensitive rods
and cones reside, and
a pigmented layer that
helps reduce the
scatter of light around
the photoreceptors of
the retina. Due to a
fluke of our embryology,
the neural layer of
the fetal retina in humans
and other vertebrates
differentiates
backwards. The light
-sensitive rods and cones
lie deep to the bipolar
interstitial neurons
and ganglionic cells,
which are in direct
line of sight of the
light rays. This means
light has to pass through
this mesh of extra,
non-light-sensitive
material before it hits
our photoreceptors.
For comparison,
the convergently
evolved eyes of
cephalopods, such as
octopus and squid, have
their photoreceptors
arranged the opposite
way, so they are
the first structures
to come in contact
with light rays.
This roundabout way
of getting light
information back to the
brain has produced two
important anatomical
structures within
the eye. One structure
can be seen at the
convergence of all the
neurons of the optic
nerve. This is called
the optic disc, and
it is so dense with
neurons that light
cannot effectively
********* it, resulting
in no photoreceptors
being placed there.
This forms a
blind spot in our
eye. To offset
this, our brains
incorporate some
post-production
trickery to fill
in that blind spot.
On the opposite
end is the macula
lutea. This is a
small depression in
the neural layer
formed by the sloping
of the non
-photoreceptor cells away
from the angle of
incoming light.
At the center of
the macula lutea,
the sloping of the
non-photoreceptive
cells produces
the most direct
access to light for
our photoreceptors,
resulting in the
clearest vision.
This area is called the
fovea or fovea centralis.
Here we see a
histological
slice through the fovea.
Even though most of
the non-photoreceptive
cells have been
pushed to the
side, there is still
a hefty amount of
non-photoreceptive
mesh to cut through
before reaching
these photoreceptors.
Whenever you focus
on an object, you
turn your eye towards
it so that the
image of the object
hits your fovea.
This behavior is
called foveation.
Both of these ocular
structures can
be viewed with an
ophthalmoscope.
The optic disc will
always pop out,
whereas the macula,
because there are
no blood vessels
directly in it, will
often look like a
faint, dark disc.
An important function
of the eyes is the
ability to change the
focal point based on where
an object is in three
-dimensional space.
This is called
accommodation.
To get a focused
image on the back
of our eyes, light
rays need to be bent
into focus as they
enter the eye.
This is done
via refraction.
Light refraction in
the eye is a two-part
process that starts
when light passes
through the cornea. The
cornea is the largest
contributor to
refraction in the eye.
It is responsible
for two-thirds of the
bending of light rays
to focus an image.
The remaining one
-third comes from the
lens, which fine
-tunes the image to
hit the back of the
eyes just right.
The lens by itself is
spherical and elastic.
To adjust the
focal point of the
eyes, the lens
must be deformed.
Objects that are far
away reflect parallel
light rays. To focus
on them, the lens needs
to be stretched and
made thinner. This
reduces its refractive
power, allowing only
for a slight bend to
incoming light rays.
This action is
largely done passively
as the tension of
the zonular fibers
pulls on the lens,
thinning it out.
Objects that are close
to the eye reflect
divergent light rays,
requiring a wider lens
to more strongly bend
the light into focus.
This is an active
process from our eyes,
as parasympathetic
innervation from the
oculomotor nerve,
via the short ciliary
nerves, is required
to stimulate
contraction of the
ciliary body and loosen
the zonular fibers,
allowing the lens to
return to its normal,
spherical shape.
And this is
the part where
it gets counterintuitive.
Because the act
of changing the
lens shape is
a passive one.
No nerve stimulation
is required to
focus on objects
in the distance.
In contrast,
returning the lens to
its normal spherical
shape requires
the eye to contract
the ciliary body
and loosen those
zonular fibers.
This is why our
eyes get tired
after reading or
staring at a screen
for a long time.
the ciliary body
has been contracted
for too long.
Since light typically
travels in a straight
line and the retina
covers the entire
back half of our
spherical eye, our retina
and vision are actually
broken into two
hemispheres per eye.
The retina is divided
into a temporal
hemiretina that covers
the side of the eye
closest to the temporal
bones and a nasal
hemiretina that covers
the side of the eye
closest to the nose.
This divides our
visual field into a
temporal visual field
that covers the half
of our vision closest
to the side of
our face, and a nasal
visual field that
covers light rays
coming closer to the
nose. You will go
into much more detail
on vision later
during neuroanatomy.
For now, the big takeaway
from this picture
is that each hemiretina
receives light
input from the opposite
visual field. For
example, the nasal visual
field will send light
rays to the temporal
hemiretina, and vice
versa. If you find
yourself confused by
this, remember to view
light rays as traveling
in straight lines, and
just draw a straight
line into the eye
from any visual angle.
Neurons from each
hemiretina travel
back to the brain
differently. While
all the optic neurons
pass through this
junction, called
the optic chiasm,
only the neurons
from our nasal
hemiretinas cross
over, or decasate,
at the chiasm,
and then travel to
the contralateral
side of the brain.
Again, this is a
relatively brief summary
of vision. You will
learn much more
about this in neuroanatomy
next semester.
Clinical correlate.
As our most important
special sense, there
are no shortage of
clinical correlates for
vision. By far the most
common is simply the
effects of age. As
we age, our lenses
lose their elasticity,
making it harder for
the lens to bounce back
to its original,
spherical shape, which is
necessary for looking
at close-up objects.
Even though we use
muscular contraction to
look at objects that are
close up, the contraction
only loosens the
attachments of the
zonular fibers. There is
no way for our body to
force our lens to
return to its original
shape once that elasticity
has started to go.
We've all seen
parents, grandparents,
and professors do
the pull-object
-away-from-face
technique to read the
words. This is a
behavioral adjustment
for the reduced
close-up vision.
Treatment is
typically glasses or
contacts, with the
relatively new ability
to use multifocal
presbylasic as a way
to change the
cornea's refractive
ability to accommodate
the stiffer lens.
As with the rest
of the body,
the lens is
comprised of cells.
Normal wear and tear
causes the breakdown of
proteins in these cells.
As we age, the rate
of repair to these
denatured proteins starts
to diminish, resulting
in the lens thickening
with what amounts
to cellular garbage.
Eventually, this
thickening can lead
to a cloudiness
called a cataract. If
left untreated,
the cataract will
eventually cause
blindness as it diffuses
more and more light
across the retina.
Cataracts can be
exacerbated by other
underlying
problems such as
hypertension, poor
nutrition, and smoking.
Cataracts also have
a strong genetic
component to them
and can be brought
on by other congenital
disorders such
as Down syndrome or
Turner's syndrome.
In all cases, cataracts
require surgical
intervention to fix.
This is usually done via
a partial or total lens
replacement depending
on the degree of
cataract cloudiness.
In a healthy person,
aqueous humor is
continuously produced
by the ciliary
body and distributed
across the anterior
chamber of the
eye where it will
drain from the
scleral venous sinus,
which is otherwise known
as the canal of Schlem.
Aqueous humor is
important for proper
nutrition to the
cornea, and when that
flow pattern gets
blocked, the humor can
start to stagnate
and become cloudy.
This cloudiness is
called glaucoma,
and it's usually
caused by a
blockage of that
drainage system.
There are two common
forms of glaucoma.
Open-angled glaucoma
has the scleral venous
sinus blocked by some
of the trabecular
meshwork comprising
the canal itself.
This can lead to a
slow-forming glaucoma.
The second form
is called closed
-angle glaucoma,
and it is caused by
the angle between
the iris and scleral
venous sinus
being too acute.
blocking access to
the canal entirely.
Closed angle glaucoma
is usually more of
a medical emergency
than open angle as
the pressure buildup
happens a lot faster.
Finally, we have
retinal detachment.
Remember that the
retina forms two layers,
a pigmented layer
next to and tightly
adhered to the choroid,
and a neural layer
that has the
photoreceptors on it. The
neural layer is not
tightly adhered and
requires constant
pressure from the aqueous
and vitreous humor
to maintain contact
with the capillary
bed of the choroid.
Any type of eye
damage that reduces
intraocular pressure
puts the retina at risk.
Patients who suffer
retinal detachment
complain of flashes
of light or of
constant specks of
light in their vision.
Retinal detachment is
considered a medical
emergency as the
neural layer of the
retina is very
intolerant of hypoxia
and cell death can
happen very quickly.
This brings us to
the end of video two.
Special Afferents
of the Head and
Neck. Video 3.
Cranial Nerve 8.
Vestibulocochlear.
Hearing and Balance.
The vestibulocochlear
nerve comes off the
pond's medulla junction
and follows the
facial nerve out of
the endocranium via
the internal acoustic
meatus. The nerve
starts as a single
structure leaving the
brain, but it quickly
splits into two
nerves as it reaches
its destination within
the inner ear. These
two nerves are the
vestibular nerve and
the cochlear nerve.
The vestibular nerve
handles the vestibular
system, the area
associated with balance,
whereas the cochlear
nerve covers the
cochlea, which is
the organ of hearing.
Although both vestibulocochlear
and facial enter
the internal acoustic
meatus, only the
facial nerve exits
the skull. The
vestibulocochlear nerve
only goes as far as the
inner ear. The nerve
splits into finer nerves
that receive sensory
information from a
specialized organ
called the otic capsule.
The otic capsule
consists of a bony or
endosseous labyrinth.
This is a set of cavities
filled with a fluid
called perilymph.
Perilymph has a
consistency similar to
most extracellular
fluids. Just deep to
the perilymph covered
endosteous labyrinth
is a secondary
structure called the
membranous labyrinth.
This is where the
hearing and balance
organs really function.
The membranous
labyrinth is filled
with endolymph, a
positively charged
substance similar to
intracellular fluid.
The membranous
labyrinth can be divided
into the vestibular
organ and the cochlea.
The vestibular organ
provides our sense
of balance and direction.
It is comprised
of two different
structures, the
otolith organs and the
semicircular canals.
There are two
otolith organs,
the utricle and the
saccule. They are
responsible for
detecting change in
direction. They do
this via two expansions
of the bony labyrinth
that house many
small calcifications
called otoliths.
Otolith, literally
translated,
means ear rock.
These little
calcifications give
weight to the gelatin
inside the saccule
and utricle.
Embedded within
that jelly are
the cilia of
sensory neurons.
The utricle is aligned
horizontally in
the head with the
sensory neurons placed
along the floor of
the utricle in an area
called the macula.
This lets the utricle
act as a horizontal
acceleration sensor,
letting us know
where our head is in
space. Data from the
utricle is compared to
semicircular canal
data to further
determine where our head
is oriented. We will
cover the semicircular
canals in a bit.
The saccule has a
similar construction
as the utricle,
but it is placed on
the medial wall
of the vestibular
organ. The saccule
detects vertical
motion and acts as
our gravity sensor.
Lastly, we have the
semicircular canals.
These provide
information on head
tilt and position
in space. We have
three semicircular
canals, the anterior,
posterior, and lateral
semicircular canal.
The anatomy of all three
canals is the same.
Each canal is filled
with endolymph, and
each canal ends in an
expanded section called
the ampulla. Inside
the ampulla resides
the ampullary crests,
or crista ampullari.
These crests protrude
into the membranous
labyrinth and house
multiple stereocilia
attached to sensory
neurons. Each semicircular
canal works as a pair
with a semicircular
canal from the other
side of the head.
This allows us to
accurately determine our
head rotation and
orientation in space.
The three opposing
pairs of semicircular
canals are the left
and right horizontal,
the right anterior
and left posterior,
and the left anterior and
right posterior
semicircular canals.
As the head rotates
in space, these three
semicircular
canals switch their
endolymphatic fluid
around, pushing on the
ampullary crests and
bending them one way
or the other. This
bending causes
depolarization of afferent
neurons on the side
that the head is
turning towards, while
hyperpolarizing,
or inhibiting, the
aferrit neurons on the
contralateral side.
This asymmetric
firing of neurons
allows the brain
to determine
which way the
head is turning.
These movements can
seem confusing at first.
The key part to
remember is that your
brain is just measuring
the difference in
signal intensity
between the paired
semicircular canals in your
head. So, for instance,
if you turn your
head to the left,
then your left
horizontal semicircular
canal would increase
signal intensity, whereas
your right horizontal
semicircular
canal would decrease
its signal intensity.
The second portion of the
otic capsule
is the cochlea.
Cochlea means
spiral, and it earned
its name from
the snail shell
shape that it
takes in the ear.
As part of our
hearing system,
the cochlea sends all its
information to the
cochlear nerve.
Inside the cochlea,
the membranous
labyrinth continues as
the spiral ligament,
and within the
spiral ligament is
the endolymph-filled
cochlear duct.
The walls of the spiral
ligament create a
barrier that separates
the rest of the
endosseous labyrinth
into two channels, the
perilymph-filled scala
vestibuli and scala
tympani. To understand
how sound travels
through the cochlea,
we have to start in
the middle ear. At the
tympanum, sound waves
shake the tympanic
membrane, transmitting
those sound waves
to the attached ear
ossicles, the malleus,
incus, and stapes. It
is at the footplate
of the stapes that
the sound waves reach
the cochlea. The
footplate of the stapes
taps on a special window
on the cochlea called
the oval window.
This sends a pressure
wave into the perilymph
of the endosseous
labyrinth through the
scala vestibulae. This
pressure wave distorts
the cochlear duct,
stimulating afferent
neurons placed in a
specialized region of
the duct called the
organ of corti. This
structure houses sensory
neurons with cilia
encased in jelly similar
to the otolith organs
and the ampullary crests
of the semicircular
canals. These
neurons depolarize at
different harmonic
frequencies, sending their
information back to
the brain via the
cochlear nerve. That
pressure wave is then
translated to the other
channel, the scala
tympani, where its energy
is eventually released
through the round
window of the cochlea.
This is all a very
basic rundown of
sound transduction,
which you will learn
more about in
neuroanatomy. The
frequency of sound waves
entering the middle
ear determine how
far up the spiral
cochlea that sound
wave will go. Lower
sounds travel further
up the spiral.
Due to the large size
difference between our
tympanic membrane and
the footplate of the
stapes, all sounds get
naturally amplified
on their way to the
cochlea. To keep from
destroying the cochlear
membrane with very loud
sounds, we have two
built-in safeties. Those
two little ear muscles
we talked about in
the previous lecture
series, tensor tympani
and stapedius. These
little muscles lock down
the ear ossicles and
dull incoming sounds.
Clinical correlate.
Hearing loss is,
of course, the most
common clinical case
associated with the
vestibulocochlear
nerve and the ear.
Hearing loss can be
congenital, or it can
be acquired from
being around very loud
noises for an extended
period of time.
Hearing loss can
be divided into
two types, conductive
hearing loss
and sensorineural
hearing loss.
Conductive hearing
loss affects the
middle ear and is a
problem with either
the tympanum or
the ear ossicles.
A perforated tympanic
membrane or scarring
around the ear
ossicles caused by an
untreated case of
otitis media can result
in dulled sounds
reaching the cochlea.
People with conductive
hearing loss typically
speak quieter than
normal as they hear
their own voice louder
than anything around
them. This type of
hearing loss can be
treated surgically or
with a hearing aid.
Sensory neural hearing
loss is another matter
entirely. It is a
problem with the inner
ear and can include
the loss of the sensory
hair cells in the
cochlea, or it can
incorporate the cochlear
nerve itself and any
of its relays along
the way to the brain.
Treatments require
cochlear implants. However,
even these implants
produce only crude
improvements compared
to natural hearing.
Tinnitus is by far the
most common hearing
problem, affecting
some 15-20% of the
U.S. population. It
is associated with
aging as hair cells
from higher frequency
regions of the cochlea
start disappearing.
The result is a
ringing sensation
in the ear whenever the
brain checks on
that frequency.
Tinnitus is not
actually a disease, but
instead is a symptom
of a larger problem.
Tinnitus can be acquired
earlier in life by
people living or working
in very loud areas.
The ringing is
constant and typically
does not require an
outside stimulus.
The rates of tinnitus
and sensorineural
hearing loss have
been on the rise
as an entire
generation has grown up
listening to music
through earbuds.
There has been
roughly a 30% increase
in hearing loss among
young adults over
the past 20 years.
The underlying problem
is that most
earbuds don't form a
tight seal around
the external auditory
meatus, resulting
in sound leaking out
into the world and
making sounds coming
from those earbuds
appear too quiet.
The response to this
is often to raise
the volume to a listenable
level, resulting
in high decibel
sound waves hitting
the ear for extended
periods of time.
The vestibular system
is not immune to
pathologies either. A
common pathology for the
vestibular system
is benign paroxysmal
position vertigo. This
pathology is caused when
otoliths break free
from the utricle. These
otoliths find their
way into one of the
semicircular canals,
where they push against
the ampullary crests,
producing conflicting
signals about head
position to the brain.
There are multiple
causes behind
BPPV, ranging from
head trauma to age
-related tissue
weakening to the most
common reason that
it just happens.
Patients with BPPV
experience intense
and debilitating
dizziness and nausea.
The effect can
last for minutes to
days and, in really
bad cases, months.
Most cases of BPPV
resolve themselves over
time as the free
-floating otoliths are
broken down and
reabsorbed by the body.
There are treatment
options that
can speed up this
process, such as
canolith
repositioning, which is
otherwise known as
the Epley maneuver.
This technique helps
to move the rogue
otoliths out of the
offending semicircular
canal and back into
the vestibule, where
they won't cause
vertigo and will get
reabsorbed faster. In
extreme cases, surgery
may be required
to free an otolith
that has gotten hung
up on a nerve bundle.
As with olfaction
and gustation,
the eyes and
vestibular system are
another instance
of a coupled
sense, the vestibulo
-ocular reflex.
This reflex is
necessary for
proper gaze
stabilization.
We are moving our
heads and bodies around
constantly. If our
eyes did not compensate
for the rotation
of our heads, the
world would look like
a bad found footage
movie. The vestibulo
-ocular reflex
uses information relayed
from the vestibular
system through the
vestibular nerve.
Balance information
passes through several
different nuclei
in the brain before
reaching the motor
nerves for the eyes.
These motor nerves
activate the appropriate
extraocular muscles
for each eye,
allowing our eyes to
compensate for the
jittery movements of
our heads and bodies,
and keeping our view
of the world stable.
You can test this
for yourself by
holding an object
in front of your
face and rotating
your head around
while focusing
on that object.
However, to really see
the vestibulo-ocular
reflex in motion, we
need to turn to birds.
Bird eyes are so large
relative to their
skull that the
extraocular muscles are
not able to do much
to adjust the eyes.
Birds compensate
for their lack
of eye movement
by turning their
entire heads to
see something.
To maintain gaze
stabilization, the vestibulo
-ocular reflex of birds
incorporates their
neck muscles, allowing
their extremely flexible
necks to act the same
way our extra-ocular
muscles act, leading
to this wonderful
example from a 2013
Mercedes-Benz commercial.
Clinical Coralip A
delay in the vestibulo
-ocular reflex
produces nystagmus,
or an unwanted
saccade of the eyes as
they attempt to
adjust to delayed
information from the
vestibular system.
Nystagmus can be
acquired through
alcohol and
heavy drug use.
Nystagmus is a
common symptom
looked for by
police when testing
to see if someone
is intoxicated.
Nystagmus can also be
acquired congenitally.
The majority of
nystagmus cases are
benign and do not
require medical
intervention. In
rare instances of
persistent debilitating
nystagmus, a
pharmacological
treatment can be offered.
This brings us
to the end of the
lecture and the
end of video 3.